otra vez un viaje del Primer Ministro
israelí Benjamín en tañejo el exterior
se ve envuelto por las protestas contra
la reforma judicial en este caso son
automovilistas que se movilizan dentro y
en los alrededores del Aeropuerto
Internacional bengurion de tel aviv
antes del viaje de netanyahu a Berlín
estos automovilistas circulan a Baja
velocidad para generar interrupciones en
el tráfico y también entonan distintas
consignas en favor de la Democracia o
tildando a neta ñahu de dictador o de
enemigo de la democracia en este viaje
en el taller tiene previsto reunirse con
el canciller Alemán olas olafones por
primera vez desde su regreso al cargo de
Primer Ministro un viaje que según
informó la oficina de neta Yahoo se ha
visto recortado por preocupaciones de
seguridad ligadas a una explosión
ocurrida Hace unos días en el norte de
Israel que dejó una persona herida y del
que se tienen escasos detalles pese a
tener distintos flancos abiertos e
incluso tensiones diplomáticas con la
Unión Europea las reforma judicial Sigue
avanzando en el parlamento último
proyecto en ser tratado es el que no le
permitiría a la Corte Suprema
inhabilitar a ministros nombrados por el
gobierno Pese a que tengan condenas por
crímenes esto apunta principalmente a
que el Ultra ortodoxo arie de Eric quien
fue condenado por evasión fiscal pueda
volver al gabinete de netanyahu y estas
protestas son también la antesala de lo
que se espera para este jueves un nuevo
día de disrupción con manifestaciones en
distintos puntos de